[Music]
I have waited so long for this
we will sacrifice
are you waiting for it let's get out
there
go show the most darling can do
the Legion is growing there aren't
enough of us we need to find help from
every planet in atlas
[Music]
the more of us there are the stronger
each of us is exactly
you must feed might lead to another
Christ isn't going to stop until we end
this
[Music]
I will finish this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you hello everyone I'm Laurel
Melville creative director on storing
battle fretless last year revealed our
muderer starship innovation to the world
and showed you how players could
reconfigure it instantly to adapt to any
challenge this year we're excited to
show you what do the depth of the open
world that we've built and put the game
directly into your hands we're going to
take you on a journey 400 light-years
away from Earth to the Atlas star system
discover exotic planets meet fascinating
local factions and forge your Alliance a
grades your pilots starships and gear
and unleash devastating combos to save a
class from the relentless forgotten
Legion the mission will not be easy
Atlas is a dangerous place and our
heroes will need all the help they can
get
could use a little help here
[Music]
hear me
let's rock and roll boys
[Applause]
[Music]
you know everyone
hello everyone it is an honor to welcome
stuff folks installing battle for Atlas
isn't it all it's amazing
ever since I started working on Starling
I wanted to invite Fox and his crew into
the game and Star Fox on Super Nintendo
was the first 3d game I've ever played
I'll never forget that and so for me
this moment is a dream come true and
this dream was only made possible thanks
to our long relationship with Nintendo
we can't wait to play fox under Nintendo
switch I would like to give you to give
a special thanks to a dear friend with
wizards in the audience today ladies and
gentlemen mr. Miyamoto
[Applause]
[Applause]
how are you
[Applause]
I know you were coming today so I came
with a gift you know it's the first
prototype of the vessel that's your
research so do you like it super so
thank you very much so it is actually a
vessel that has been created by the team
and they they would be so happy to see
you backstage so let's go and join them
thank you
Thank You mr. Miyamoto and thank you Eva
for everyone at e3 please be sure to
come by the Ubisoft booth where we'll
have a full hands-on demo for you to try
for everyone else
Starlin will launch on all consoles on
October 16th with Star Fox as an
exclusive Nintendo switch experience
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you so much check out starting
game.com
to pre-order the game right after the
conference thank you so much for being
here today and have a great
[Applause]